what
is deep work let's start with a big
question
so i mean it's my term for when you're
focusing without distraction
on a cognitively demanding task which
is something we've all done but we had
never really given it a name
necessarily that was separate from other
type of work and so
i gave it a name and said let's compare
that to other types of efforts you might
do
while you're working and see that the
deep work efforts actually have
a huge benefit that we might be
underestimating what does it mean to
to work deeply on something i you know i
had been calling it hard focus
in my writing uh before that well so the
context you would understand i was in
the theory group
in seasal at mit right so i was
surrounded at the time when i was coming
up with these ideas
by these professional theoreticians and
that's like a murderer's row
of thinkers there right i mean it's like
turing award touring award macarthur
tauren award i mean
you know the crew right theoretical
computer science theoretical computer
science yeah
yeah so so i'm in the theory group right
between theoretical computer science
uh and i publish a book so you know so i
was in this milieu where i was being
exposed to people
uh where focus was their tier one skill
like that's what you would talk about
right
like how how intensely i can focus that
was the
v key skill it's like your 4 40 time or
something if you were
an athlete right so so this is something
that people
actually the the the theory folks are
thinking about oh yeah
really like they're openly discussing
like how do you focus
i mean i don't know if they would you
know quantify it but
but focus was the tier one skill so you
you would come in
here would be a typical day you'd come
in uh and eric domain would be sitting
in front of a white board
yeah right with a whole group of
visitors who had come to work with them
and maybe they projected like a grid on
there because they're working on some
graph theory problem you go to lunch you
go to the gym
you come back they're sitting there
staring at the same
same white board right like that's the
tier one skill this is the difference
between different disciplines like i
i often feel for many reasons like a
fraud
but i definitely feel like a fraud when
i hang out with like either
mathematicians or physicists
it's like it feels like they're doing
the legit work
because when you talk with closer in
computer science you get to programming
or like machine learning like the the
the experimental machine learning or
like
just the engineering version of it it
it's it feels like you're
gone so far away from what's required to
solve something fundamental about this
universe it feels like you're just like
cheating your way into like some kind of
trick to figure out how to solve a
problem in this one particular case
yeah that's how it feels right and it's
uh
i'd be interested to hear what you think
about that because um
programming doesn't always feel like
you need to think deeply to work deeply
but sometimes it does so it's a weird
dance
for sure code does right i mean
especially if you're coming up with
original
algorithmic designs i think it's a great
example of deep work
i mean yeah the the hardcore
theoreticians they push it to an extreme
i mean
i think it's like knowing that athletic
endeavor is good
and then hanging out with a olympic
athlete like oh i see that's what it is
now for the grad students like me we're
not anywhere near that level but the
faculty
the faculty in that group these were the
cognitive
olympic athletes but coding i think is a
classic example of deep work because
i got this problem i want to solve i
have all of these tools
and i have to combine them somehow
creatively and on the fly but so
basically i had been exposed to that
so i was used to this notion when i was
in grad school and i was writing my blog
i'd write about hard focus
you know that was the term i used then i
published this book
so good they can't ignore you which came
out in 2012 so like right as i began as
a professor and that book had this
notion of
skill being really important for career
satisfaction that it's not just
following your passion
you have to actually really get good at
something and then you use that skills
as leverage and there's this big
follow-up question to that book of okay
well how do i get really good at this
yeah and then i look back to my grad
school experience i was like huh
there's this focus thing that we used to
do i wonder how
generally applicable that is into the
knowledge sector and so as i started
thinking about it
it became clear there's this interesting
storyline that emerged that okay
actually undistracted concentration is
not just important for
esoteric theoreticians it's important
here it's important here and so forth
here
and that involved into the the deep work
hypothesis which is
across the whole knowledge work sector
focus is very important and we've
accidentally created circumstances where
we just don't do a lot of it
you